- So I took Nick
to the Pioneer Saloon,
which is
in Goodsprings, Nevada.
It's a little ghost town
up in the hills,
and I heard that there
was gonna be
some Ford trucks there.
I want him to see
how they look done,
give him some more input.
Then that way, he'll be able
to have a better idea
of what he wants.
This one's
more or less
a customized, uh, '48.
It's got tilt front end
on it.
- It's black.
- It's custom flames.
This is a '56, just like yours,
and this one here--
this is probably
the most customized truck
I've seen out there.
You can notice
all of it, right?
The ordinary person
to walk up to this,
he wouldn't know.
He's just say,
"Oh, that's a cool truck."
- Hey, Rick!
- How you doing?
- Good to see you.
- Mike told me
you were out here, looking.
- Hey guys. Hey, guys.
Gary, did you build this?
- Yes.
- You did?
Cut two cabs apart,
put 21 extension on...
- Right.
- And, uh...
- Took a piece to the dash?
Right?
Took a--one of the--
- Yes.
Had two humps and two trucks,
so I said, "Let's put
the other one over there."
- Yeah, make it--
- I got two speedometers now.
- [laughs]
Yeah, it's got a lot of work.
- The bed is six months' worth
of varnishing on that.
- Oh, wow.
- Underneath is just as shiny
as on top.
- Oh, yeah.
See?
Now, that's a frame.
- [laughs]
- That's that
custom-made frame.
- Yeah.
- Winters Quick-change
rear end.
- Yeah.
- I can change it
and get it ready to show
in 20 minutes.
- Tell me, you know the time
you spent on it.
How much time?
- 25 years.
[laughter]
- That's gotta be
a lot of money.
- 300,000.
I ran out of money three times.
[laughter]
- I think this definitely
showed Nick
that--that it's
blood, sweat, and tears
to get this thing done,
but at the same time,
this isn't just about
what Nick can't do.
You know, Nick could've.
He wants to, I can tell,
but he just doesn't
have the time.
He really doesn't,
so for me to be able to bring
a little bit
of his dreams into it
would be worthwhile.